this is a complicated subject but i i
myself was so
i decided to journey out from the world
of being a researcher at mit
and potentially doing a startup myself
and i've been thinking of you know i
wanted to come to silicon valley to do
so
it's the land of the entrepreneur and
there's a lot of my friends
a lot of them are successfully have been
entrepreneurs themselves
have said do not come to silicon valley
uh
it'd be you've you've started you you
ran amazing teams of engineers you
started a lot of
successful businesses i i wondered if
you could comment on
why a lot of people are leaving
california is there something that could
be fixed about california
if you were starting a business today
would you consider
somewhere else like austin or some other
place
or is silicon valley still is it just a
little lull
everybody's being over dramatic during
uh this particular year of the
coronavirus and so on
i think you know even austin's getting
overheated i hear um yes and i've had
relatives and friends moved to texas
within the last few months so
texas as a whole is a big place and you
know people are moving to florida
there's a big movement toward miami
um peter thiel keith where will all
these people um the mayor has been very
business friendly about it which i think
is just good politics
america is fundamentally a commercial
republic so you would think this would
be what's happening
for a long time california was the
golden state i came here in late 76 when
i was a teenager
it's in crushing debt due to the
lockdowns it's
got the highest taxes that's gotta
matter people do fleet
high taxes um it's got uh
likely fires every year because of the
deadfall it's not global warming
it's because the forests weren't managed
like they had been in the first part of
the 20th century um
just i would say corruption at all
levels especially up to the governor who
you know famously was eating at the
french laundry in a
yes claimed the outside it was inside
and they were masks off and it was great
uh do what i say not what i do
uh rules for thee but not for me
when you see that in leadership people
either run or they
they get rid of the leadership so
there's a recall drive which is about to
reach the threshold
or in the old days they get their guns
right you don't put up with this junk
but ultimately the thing that made
silicon valley a special place
it gave freedom to like young kids
entrepreneurs
young minds brave minds to think bold to
try different stuff
i mean even if the taxes are high so
outside of financial stuff outside of
all of that
housing's super expensive housing yeah
so it's hard
okay everything about students was
narrow and they didn't plan the roads
right yeah
they got rid of public transportation in
l.a like the who framed roger rabbit
cartoon show they used to have trolley
cars
in portland too the oil companies and
the dod
conspired to build highways and make
cars dominant and
the rights of way are long gone like
elon's going to go underground
and i rush him well yeah that's probably
the only way to do it now yeah
but is it still a place do you think
it's possible that silicon valley is
still a place where magic happens were
the next googles built where the next
i mean brave is built where uh
i think all good things come to an end i
think the problem is silicon valley had
strong network effects through stanford
through
uh the angel investor networks and the
wealth effect and
originally you have to give the federal
government credit like the arpanet was a
government
project that's not kid ourselves this
wasn't wild free market you know
libertarian capitalism this was all
cold war stuff um you had uh
out of the academia you had shockley and
then the the traitorous aid and
fairchild and intel and
but now you know when's the last fab
that was built in the valley
micro unity might have been the last i
don't know i haven't followed but we
built a fab in sunnyvale and
uh in micro unity in starting early 90s
and now the fabs are overseas um
and the the one thing that i would say
that the oligarchs have intentionally
done
in both parties is sort of
labor and environmental protection law
arbitrage by going where the labor's
cheaper and the environmental laws
aren't restrict
and you know that's polluted the hell
out of parts of china but it's made
things
you can make cheaper junk yeah and uh
this this is not
uh this is not a story that's over yet
so what is silicon valley for now it's
for the network effect the
the brain trust of who you know the
parties
the stanford um sort of network
that's fragile too over time i'm afraid
right stanford
a lot of good professors i like uh they
still filter you know
mainly based on socioeconomic status but
it's kind of a skate school
i had a friend uh hired out of harvard
20 years ago at
netscape and we talked about harvard and
he said yeah they're still professors
are great on the curve and i said oh
yeah i don't think they're any doing
that at stanford
and he said oh it was shocking some of
the students got c's and d's and they
were crying
it's like yes that's right the the
precious deers can't take that at
stanford so they get a's and b's
yeah now you look at china and people
say what you all about china
they improve russia too a lot of math
science training a lot of engineering a
lot of people who are
doing their course work to get the a's
and the b's so
um i'm an american i'm born in the
fourth of july
early fourth of july yeah wow and
america as i say fundamentally is a
commercial republic you can
try to make it something else you can
say it's the new atlantis and mystify it
you could you could talk about it in a
more i think correct way which is 13
colonies that grew and then
there's a lot of local or in the
original design anyway the federal
federalist papers talk about this
there's a lot of subsidiarity
but that's that's been eroded over time
and
like i say a lot of the offshoring has
hurt so what happened with coronavirus
people working from home and at first it
was funny because i have friends at
google who
used to grumble that not only did they
have to come into the office if they
joined a different team that was
centered in a different office they had
to move
or you know if if the v8 team was
reconstituted in munich which it was
after
lars bach just got tired of javascript
that they hired in munich or they hired
phds in germany and moved them to munich
with chronovirus everyone's working from
home and it's like what a relief i can
work for google from home
but then the next few dropped and people
started asking mark zuckerberg hey can i
move to
my hometown in the midwest yeah and he
said okay and they said oh can i keep
getting my silicon valley pay
no we're going to figure out what your
cost of living there is and we're going
to adjust your pay accordingly
and and these colonies and these little
mini experiments that all combine to the
big giant experiment i
have a i don't know i have this uh
vision of america which the country i
was born in russia like i said here and
this is
truly a wonderful country i'm i wasn't
born in the fourth of july people still
here people still flee i still and i'm
uh
red blooded america at this point and i
have a sense that we figured it out
somehow
if silicon valley burns another place
will come up in its place
that even more innovation and people
will move
and the remote work might change
fundamentally
how we work or might not it might just
give you the freedom to then create
many other small silicon valleys
throughout the place like austin
included but other places as well
and we somehow figured it figured it out
and uh
i think that's that's true that there
will be more mobility and maybe new
places that come up
i don't know if silicon valley has you
know
passed some sell-by date because um
it did hurt the chronovirus hurt the
lockdowns hurt and the fact in the sense
that
part of what keeps things going is
social and so a lot of young people
even before chronovirus moved to san
francisco it was very strange to watch
because in the 80s we all lived in the
valley and
it was less populated in san francisco
it was grungier it was more like
dirty harry in the 70s yes but but by
the 90s
uh and jamie runs a nightclub there he's
talked about this you had sort of
wealthy tech people moving in south of
market fancy townhouses being built
and uh that's continued and such a point
that it's almost like
what's the movie by the south african
director and there's jodie foster up in
the space colony uh
matt damon is the guy on the earth who
has to go up and anyway
it's about the stratification it's about
the great inequality the people in the
space station have
like amazing medical auto docs that can
extend their life or save them cure
cancer
people on earth are all suffering ground
down in poverty
and uh you know that sort of happened
while i was here you saw
a lot of money drive prices up
along the narrow peninsula and the
single people wanted nightlife they were
in the city
and the condos in the city got super
expensive and you i know
even google friends who are you know
socially responsible say we should have
more
housing built we should have yes in my
backyard not not in my backyard
but that's not happening as far as i can
tell and
from the government to the incumbent you
know landowners and renters
it's just not happening and that has to
drive people away i
i i appreciate that people come here and
you should wait for the prices to
monitor yeah
they will but but a lot of people are
going to go where the
prices are lower
you